TO Q SO CONTROVERSIAL.
CHOOSE A HUMAN BEING OVER
PORNOGRAPHY, AS WE SAID HEAT
REPRESENTS MISSOURI IN THE U.S.
SENATE ENJOINS US TONIGHT TO
EXPLAIN HIS SPEECH.
SENATOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
TELLIS WHY, I MEAN YOU'RE A U.S
SENATOR, YOU HELPED NEGOTIATE
TRADE DEALS, BUT YOU MENTIONED
HUMAN RELATIONSHIPS, WHY?
>> SOMEBODY'S GOT TO BE HONEST
AND TELL THE TRUTH TO THESE
YOUNG MEN IN THE TRUTH IS THAT
THE INDUSTRY IS SELLING THEM A
LIE AND AMERICAN SOCIETY NEEDS
THEM WE NEED THEM TO STEP UP, W
NEED THEM TO GO GET MARRIED AND
HAVE FAMILIES AND BE RESPONSIBL
HUSBANDS AND FATHERS.
THIS SOCIETY IS IMPOVERISHED
BECAUSE TOO MANY YOUNG MEN OUR
TWO DESPAIRING OR BORED TO BE
DOING WHAT WE NEED THEM TO DO A
A COUNTRY, IT IS TIME TO CALL O
YOUNG PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR YOUN
MEN TO BE SOMETHING MORE, THEY
WANT TO BE CALLED TO THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE SOLD THE BILL OF
GOODS ANYMORE, SOMEONE NEEDS TO
TELL THEM THE TRUTH.
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT, YOU AR
ONE AT THE VERY FEW PEOPLE WHO
SAID ANYTHING LIKE THIS,
CERTAINLY WON A FEW ELECTED
OFFICIALS BECAUSE IT'S
EMBARRASSING TO NOTICE THIS IS
HAPPENING.
WHY DON'T MORE PEOPLE NOTICE
THIS.
>> I THINK THAT'S BECAUSE THE
LIBERAL CULTURE WITH THE MESSAG
TO YOUNG PEOPLE IS THE MOST YOU
CAN ASPIRE TO IN LIFE IS TO BE
CONSUMER WHO SITS IN A CUBICLE
IN FRONT OF A CAM COMPUTER ALL
DAY AND DOESN'T ASK QUESTIONS O
DO ANYTHING MEANINGFUL WITH
THEIR LIFE.
WHAT WE NEED TO SEE TWO YOUNG
MEN AND WOMEN TO ITS JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
ASPIRE TO BE SOMETHING MORE THA
A CONSUMER AND FOR YOUNG MEN
ASPIRED TO BE SOMETHING MORE
THAN CONSUMER PORNOGRAPHY CREAT
SOMETHING OF YOUR LIFE LIKE
CREATE A FAMILY FOR INSTANCE,
THAT IS THE SINGLE GREATEST ACT
OF REBELLION IF YOU LIKE AGAINS
THE LIBERAL CULTURE THAT IS
OPPRESSING PEOPLES DESIRES IN
POTENTIAL IS TO GO OUT AND
ACTUALLY ENGAGE IN REAL
RELATIONSHIPS, GET MARRIED, HAV
A FAMILY, HAVE KIDS, HAVE YOUR
OWN IDEAS AND BE RESPONSIBLE
MEMBER OF SOCIETY.
THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE ARE BUILT T
DO.
THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE WANT TO DO,
THEY WANT TO BE CHALLENGED IN
THIS WAY.
>> I'M SURE ECLIPSE OF YOU YOU
SEEING THAT ARE EVERYWHERE I
HOPE YOU KEEP SAYING IT BECAUSE
I THINK IT IS REALLY TRUE.
I TH